hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well section 9 of
William James essay the will to believe
is entitled faith may bring forth its
own verification and in this section
James is providing us with several
different analyses of examples drawn
from different areas of life that are
aimed at illustrating this very
principle and he he ends his discussion
there with this great sentence there are
cases where a fact cannot come at all
unless a preliminary faith exists in its
coming that means that unless we already
have some sort of belief commitment to
something being true or something being
the case we're not going to do what is
necessary or even just sufficient
perhaps to bring about conditions in
which that could be verified and now
this is not going to apply to you know
options and hypotheses that are not
living in James parlance or you know not
not momentous or not forced but it will
apply to things that matter quite a bit
to us and he talks about moral issues
personal matters social
issues and then a little bit later on
religious matters we're not going to
talk so much about those examples
because we're going to discuss that
elsewhere separately but he tells us
that we're a faith in a fact can help
create that fact it would be an insane
logic which would say that faith running
ahead of scientific evidence is it puts
this in quotes the lowest kind of
immorality into which a thinking being
can fall and he says yet this is the
logic by which our scientific absolutist
pretend to regulate our lives so this is
incredibly relevant in our own time when
there are so many people crowing about
things being evidence-based oftentimes
you have to be kind of careful about
their claims to that when you look at
their evidence it's actually rather
shaky the studies are often inflated
from you know very clear findings about
small canoe no small groups within very
tightly controlled circumstances to
humankind in general right but let's say
that that was actually the case there
are a lot of people who say that well
unless you've got evidence or facts on
your side thanks not feelings logic
science reason then you should keep your
mouth shut and James would say sometimes
they're right but a lot of times they're
actually wrong and the things that
matter to us the most they tend to be
wrong there are a lot of cases where by
making some sort of commitment we place
ourselves in a situation where we can
actually observe the truth in part
because it might be that we just have to
to get ourselves there but it might also
be that that action itself is part of
what's required in order to create the
situation in which these things can
precipitate out one of the examples that
I'd like to use to illustrate this which
which is not provided by James but
derives from my own experience is as a
berry picker when I was young and also
as a younger adult I would often go out
and
hit black raspberries in Windrose and
forests and things like that and as I
was doing that one of the things that I
came to realize is when you're looking
through the foliage and I'm a pretty
good woodsman because I grew up in the
countryside so I can you know I can look
through wooded areas and I can recognize
those sort of plants we're dealing with
provided I'm in an area that I know
quite well you know like the Midwest or
as it turned out Germany which has quite
similar voyage in many cases so you see
the blackberries you're like aha there's
a blackberry bush over there I'm gonna
go and start picking but it's only when
you start moving things around you're
like whoa there's even more there I
better get those and you start putting
all those into your your buckets and
pretty soon you've got a couple gallons
and you only have those couple gallons
because you didn't just go by what you
can see when you're looking at the
windrow from a distance you got up there
close you move things around you took
the risk of getting yourself cut up by
the brambles you sometimes found that
there really wasn't anything there
sometimes you saw the you know what
looked like is gonna be the very rich
place and the birds have already picked
it over other times you hit the mother
lode but it's only because you actually
did something and turn those leaves over
and got your hands in there that you
were able to get the reward so we can
draw this in a sort of diagram here
where we begin with a what James is
calling faith a belief that X is the
case could even be a hope or could be a
desire that X is the case could be also
be framed negatively I'm afraid that X
is the case and so I'm going to act in
such a way as to try to ward it off or
to deal with it or to uncover it as a
danger then that leads to some sort of
action there's a willing to do a some
sort of action willing to make a
commitment willing to take a chance
something that happens in the world and
then there's some sort of results
produced by the action
and then you can observe that X is
actually the case and the action could
be as simple as walking over here and
opening up the book and seeing what's
actually in the book as a matter of fact
another prime example of this
particularly apt in our own time so many
people will ask me questions about
something that I've discussed in in
media that they're they're watching
about some philosopher and their
doctrine and I'll say the answer over
and over again you really need to read
the book because they'll have some sort
of objection to an idea presented
essentially out of context and in
isolation from the other ideas and I'm
saying go to the native habitat of the
philosophers thought see what's actually
there
sometimes cracking open a book or
putting it on your phone or Kindle and
reading through it and seeing what's
there that can be an action but the
person who says well I I'm not going to
do that until everything has been
satisfactorily explained to me well
they're never gonna know anything then
are they and that's their own choice
James would say now he does give some
really great examples he begins by
talking about moral questions and he
says moral questions present themselves
as questions whose solution cannot wait
for sensible proof a moral question is
not of what sensibly exists but of what
is good or would be good if it did exist
science can tell us what exists but to
compare the Wirth's both of what exists
and what does not exist we must consult
that science but what Pascal calls the
heart science herself consults her heart
when she lays it down that infinite
ascertain meant of fact and correction
of false beliefs are the supreme goods
for man challenge the statement science
can only repeat it or ocularly or else
prove it by showing that assert a man
and a correction bring man all sorts of
other goods which man's heart in turn
declares so you say him at our passional
or volitional nature as he's called it
earlier now what about the question of
having moral beliefs at all or not
having
James says this is decided by our will
at some level we actually have to make a
decision and this is where we get to all
sorts of interesting quandary
where people are like you while you
virtue ethicist
why do you say that virtue is good and
then you provide them with the arguments
and they're like yeah I get those but I
I still don't see why I should accept
this and you're like well buddy you know
that's as far as we're gonna get with
this conversation
you're being sort of deliberately
perverse it's up to you whether you
think that these work or not at some
level as a friend of mine used to say
you pays your money and it takes your
chances and I think you may have gotten
that from James because he was a
pragmatist
so our moral preferences true or false
are the only odd biological phenomena
making things good or bad for us but in
themselves indifferent he says your
intellect cannot decide this you have to
decide this for yourself you have to
actually act as if that was the case and
then see what happens or act as if it's
not the case one great way to test a
moral philosophy put it into practice
see what results from it if you recoil
from it in horror well you know you made
a big mistake if things start turning
out good for you because you actually
you know applied the system and stuck
with it well there is its confirmation
right that's as good as it's going to
get for those sorts of things
he says turning now from these wide
questions of good to a certain kind of
questions of fact questions concerning
personal relations that is states of
mind between one person and another he
says let's think about liking and love
do you like me or not whether you do or
not depends and countless countless
instances on whether I meet you halfway
if I just walk up to you on the street
and I'm like hey man you like me you'd
be like I don't even know who the hell
you are get out of my face right but if
I've established a relationship with you
and after our third time meeting up with
each other at the coffee shop or in the
you know Milwaukee stoic fellowship or
you know taking the elevator and our
building I say hey do you like me you
might say no I still don't know you that
well but yeah I guess I kind of like you
you know you seem like a decent sort of
person right there has to be some sort
of involvement some sort of commitment
before that question can be answered yes
and that requires action on our part
meeting people halfway as he says he
says the previous faith on my part in
your likings existence is in such cases
what makes your liking come if I stand
aloof and refuse to budge an inch until
I have objective evidence until you have
done something apt as the absolutist say
odd export quondam odd sense of Mayim
right ten-to-one your liking never comes
the this whole Latin phrase means
extorting or deriving your assent right
and then he goes on to talk about love
and he says how many women's hearts are
vanquished by the mere sanguine
insistence of some man that they must
love him he will not consent to the
hypothesis that they cannot write and
this can go for either gender or across
gender lines or any sort of arrangement
that you want when it comes to romantic
involvement there is something about
saying the other person I want to be in
a relationship with you perhaps you
could fall in love with me that tends to
lead to that falling in love some people
actually are attracted to those who they
know are attracted to them again there's
some there's some sort of commitment
going on there
he also talks about the work world Annie
says that who gains promotions boons
appointments but the man in whose life
they are seen to play the part
notice that he's using a technical term
here of live hypotheses who discounts
them sacrifices other things for their
sake before they have come and take
risks for them in advance if you don't
start writing the book you're not going
to find out whether you can write a
great American novel if you don't apply
for the job and show up to the interview
then you can't get the job nobody's
going to like you know search the
database and say oh this is exactly the
right person I mean unless you're lucky
enough to have a headhunter working for
you or an agent in which case they're
doing that legwork they're taking the
action you've just displaced it or
outsource that to another he also talks
about social matters he says that the
reason why social organisms work is
because each member proceeds to their
duty with a trust that the other members
will simultaneously do theirs
whenever a desired results is achieved
by the cooperation of many independent
persons its existence as a fact is a
pure consequence of what James calls the
per cursive faith in one another of
those immediately concerned so when
we're in social organisms organizations
institutions even within social
situations in which we have expectations
we do our thing we have faith that it's
going to work and the other person
rewards that and the hypothesis is
thereby confirmed or verified when I go
into Starbucks and I want to get a
coffee and it's not my preferred place
to get coffee there's better ones but
you know I have a Starbucks card I go up
there and I order my triple venti latte
which is what I almost always get every
once in a while I'll have a person
behind the counter who looks at me a
little bit weird because they they
didn't get enough training or something
like that and then I say well it's a
regular venti latte with an extra shot
of espresso and they you know asked me
my name and take my card and carry out
the transaction the cup goes on to the
next person the barista who is going to
you know create the thing and I trust
they'll put in the extra shot that I
paid for and then you know they call my
name and I go and get the coffee there
there's a whole operation of things
there that I have faith in and then I
act on that and then it happens if I go
into Starbucks and I say
I'm not sure if you're gonna make me
that coffee I'll pay you after you make
that coffee and I hear you call my name
they'll look at me like I'm an idiot and
if they're really really you know bored
maybe they'll say okay buddy
weirdo will go along with that but for
the most part they'll say okay but sir
step aside we've got people in line
right and so he has this famous example
really great example a whole train of
passion passengers individually brave
enough will be looted by a few highway
men simply because the latter can count
on one another while each passenger
fears that if he makes a movement of
resistance he will be shot before anyone
else backs him up if we believed the
whole car would rise at once with us we
would each severally rise and train
robbing would never be attempted and
James says that this holds for pretty
much all of our social institutions
there are things that we have faith in
we act on that that faith gets confirmed
precisely because we acted upon it if we
were to apply this rigorous cliff 40 and
standard of I'm not going to commit
myself unless I have absolute objective
evidence that provides complete
certitude we would never get that
confirmation or verification of what it
is that we're having faith in so there
are many circumstances according to
James of our lives that involve this
very dynamic where the fact cannot come
at all as he says unless a preliminary
faith exists in that facts coming and we
act upon the basis of that faith thereby
producing the fact or the situation in
which the fact can be verified
you